welcome back to the box we're here to
talk about more Android with Nicola
welcome Nicola thanks Nicola here you're
talking about effective image
manipulation and on androids obviously
Android is a constrained environment
because it's mobile you know environment
what are the options for developers that
they can use when it comes to images and
so the options that that you can use in
your program the common ones are
probably OpenGL and native and those two
actually have a lot of issues and a lot
of constraints that you have you have to
deal with one of the recent possibility
that for android is run the script which
is a new framework a new language for
processing images that has a lot of
advantages compared to those of
solutions ok so we'll get to that and
enter your experience anything against
OpenGL specifically or native I mean
what are the shortcomings before we get
to render script and no nothing nothing
but gratitude only the only thing is
that I guess native I mean my native
what I mean is that you simply pass a
bitmap to the native side you process it
it's pretty easy to process the problem
is that if you want to optimize you are
going to have
to optimize for particle devices it's
going to be difficult optimized for
everything and compared to OpenGL it's a
bit slower you also have to give we
memory etc etc back later yeah rice with
some advantages some inconvenience
opengl good thing is that it's it should
be fast the bad thing is well support
for opengl depends on drivers and some
GPU SBS better than others okay and you
know some cheap use of constraint that
was onto not tab you have like maximum
size of textures and stuff like that all
right okay so uh so you're talking about
this because you have experience with
this and you've been building I've been
walking this past year basically on a
new photo editor in gallery yes where we
actually started the first question that
we really is the back last November last
year was mostly using native processing
we're just passing the bitmaps with a
native side doing something in c and
that's it but since then we moved a lot
more to water on the script and for
quite a few reasons the big the big
difference for us is that we want we
want the software to run on as many
devices as possible and it gets
difficult if you have to test and be a
hundred percent sure that your code in
opengl for instance is going to walk
everywhere so that's why we really went
with native even if it's not as fast as
open yet it's a lot it's a more
tractable problem to be sure that
everything will work well but if we want
to make it faster to review really good
interactive speed then opengl start to
look more appealing but then you end up
with all those issues with compatibility
and etc render script on the other hand
as with quite a few nice advantages one
of the advantage is that it's a specific
language that actually
should I it's basically c99 with vector
extensions which means that it's it's
both a good non-wage for image
processing because all those victoire
extensions you can actually write
algorithm that are cleaner and simpler
and make a lot more sense yes and at the
time at the same time it's not
particularly different than the shader
on wed or than see I mean it's in 99 it
they basically use LLVM compiler us to
generate that and then with the tech d
script and executed through nvm do a
bunch of optimization and more
importantly they couldn't in all of that
in parallel so in terms of performance
is what you get is something that is
completely paralyzed that we take
advantage of all the codes on your
device which is pretty important about
the GPU can we use the GPU as well and
that's one of the big thing this year is
that we know supports GPU drivers for on
the script okay so on all the Nexus
devices we do have GPU driver but what
does it mean do you get to choose as a
developer if it runs on one or the other
what's available you can either choose
on the truth I mean you have the option
right so if you don't do anything around
the script will just say m I'm going to
run on the fastest possible thing you
can also specify a I'm going to run on
the CPU which sometimes is is a really
good thing to do because the CPU is a
lot more predictable than 30 p you so
depending on what you do right that
might be better okay interesting so just
two people have an idea for the work
you've done this is the gallery the
editor in the gallery there's a video
online available so people and of course
yes we porsche nine and try some
commands I mean some reviews this past
week about about it so does lead
attorney and you're doing some pretty
heavy lifting with this it's not just
you know adding a simple filter and then
and it done with it right so I think
it's a good example of so what kind of
script is there you can use it it works
it's fast so give us examples of you
know I don't know you know the type of
transformation is doing or work you're
doing and the size of the image maybe
you're able to work with or yeah the
video actually walks on the arbitrary
size of sizes of images so s
non-destructive it's nondescript
we do a lot of effect not just global
effect but also local effects all the
common words I mean vignette contrast
saturation and we do we do a bunch of
interesting things like that what I'm
really happy with is that it scares very
well and yeah it's non-destructive which
means that you can always come back we
apply an affectionate and effect and
it's still going to be at the Safari
there's a pipeline that affects you
apply and you can move back to and how
about the the previews do you actually
compute this for the entire image or the
how do you how do you make that so
snappy I mean in general the way you do
it too you can't you can't actually run
everything on the full image all the
time because are going to be too slow so
once you really care about is to have
something that is fast that is very
interactive for the user so you just
cheat in earth what we doing the editors
that we compute everything on a very
small preview image and because it's
smaller you know it we can run your
stuff at an interactive interactive
speeds the UI elements themselves are
animated at 60fps so when you move
something when you move a control it
always follow your you are your actions
which is really what's the important
point the previous step is very fast and
then we have a progressive preview so as
soon as you stop moving stuff we compute
the higher resolution images and the
higher and I are until you get the final
one to an image and you have this nice
way of comparing before and after yeah
there's some some second Weiss yeah
another way you apply I mean there I
encourage people to check it out you
know as end-users maybe not as
developers so great where should people
go to learn more about the render script
there is some documentation online yeah
I'm maybe the documentation that's there
is sadly not as proper as a good life it
to be but the rondo scripting is working
on that
this pasture the focus has been low on
getting out compatibility library which
which means that it's actually very
important point it means that you can
write on the script then you can run
your application using on the scripts on
devices that go back to I think
gingerbread the transfer library better
internally we even made it run on froyo
so okay it's good that actually you know
it's very comfortable I write some code
and I know it's going to walk everywhere
that actually and yet it going to be fat
and government okay so on the the
android website there's documentation we
exactly humbly website and you know it's
gonna get better over time but but
there's something to start with great
well Nicola thanks for your time that's
what I wanted to cover here and see you
soon alright thanks